hola buenas noches pues el presidente
será tratado en el hospital walter beer
por algunos de los síntomas que está
presentando entre ellos molestias en la
garganta fatiga también se sabe según lo
ha dicho la casa blanca y su doctor
personal que ha sido es sometido a un
tratamiento experimental no aprobado aún
por la rda para tratar estos síntomas y
para el coronavirus también que se le
está dando vitamina de zinc y aspirina
otros de los aspectos importantes es que
el presidente va a permanecer en
cuarentena en el hospital y que también
se espera que desde allí pues realice
algunas de sus funciones pero no
funciones que están relacionadas con la
campaña como tal ahora tiene usted ya lo
mencionó de cara a estas elecciones que
ocurre con los eventos y actividades
para su compañía reelección y cómo
podría más afectar esto
bueno pues básicamente sería el
vicepresidente mike pence quien ha dado
negativo al igual que su esposa esta
prueba de coronavirus quien llevaría el
liderazgo en estos eventos de campaña
aunque eventos relacionados con recaudar
fondos como en el cual participó el
presidente el día de ayer con varias
personas en un evento en 'new jersey'
estos eventos ya no los realizará no se
sabe si los hará de manera virtual y
también hay cuestionamientos sobre si el
presidente podrá llegar a atender en un
futuro algún debate adicional como el
que vimos con su contrincante demócrata
joe biden quien también se hizo la
prueba y resultó negativo al igual que
su esposa es posible que también sus
hijos puedan llevar digamos la vocería
de estos eventos ya que su hija ivanka
trump y su esposo han dado negativo
también a la prueba de coronavirus
brevemente día de muchos
cuestionamientos sobre si el presidente
podrá seguir ejerciendo sus funciones
que dice la constitución al respecto
bueno que el presidente ha dicho que va
a continuar ejerciendo sus funciones la
constitución en la enmienda 25 establece
que si un presidente como tal no puede
ejercer estas funciones sería el
vicepresidente quien sería juramentado
como presidente de los eeuu pero en dado
caso de que el presidente llegara a
recuperarse después de estar en esta
enfermedad pues entonces ésta sería una
transición temporal pero por el momento
el presidente como vimos camino al
helicóptero que lo llevó al hospital y
dice que está optimista